Fox News contributor investigative
reporter Sarah Carter Fox News legal
analyst Gregg Jarrett Fox News national
security strategist former deputy
assistant to the president Sebastian
Gorka it was March 8th of last year you
and John Solomon on this show broke the
story of a FISA warrant and surveillance
at Trump Tower and how few in the media
cared to follow what is the biggest
abuse and corruption scandal in their
lifetime
Sarah it's it's incredible Shawn because
there was so much evidence out there
little bits of evidence that if they
just latched on to it they would have
been able to see through and seeing the
truth and they chose not to and what's
even more incredible is that the Obama
administration and people associated
with Hillary Clinton now we know fusion
GPS Christopher Steele Bruce or in the
DOJ Sally Yates Andrew McCabe at the FBI
former director James Comey they were
spreading the disinformation campaign
you know was interesting they tried to
say that it was the Russians but the
whole time based on an unverified and
salacious dossier and those are the
words coming out of commis own mouth
they use that to spread lies about the
Trump campaign to the media and anybody
they could try to share it with and this
is what's so incredible the media bought
it and they chose to ignore the other
side they chose to ask for verification
and the entire precedence of the Special
Counsel was based on that dossier
according to McCabe you know I even have
testimony I don't have time to play it
all we have so much information to get
out tonight Gregg Jarrett but remember
when he called me met with Donald Trump
he said it's unverified and it's
salacious but two months earlier he was
arguing just the opposite and then the
worst part is they knew where this
dossier came from and they never told
the FISA Court criminally speaking is he
in jeopardy tonight oh absolutely I mean
this is just proof of government
corruption and it's sad the FBI and the
Department of Justice they concealed
evidence and they deceived a federal
judge they knew this was a fabricated
document knew
they was paid for by Democrats in
Hillary Clinton they knew that the guy
who authored it said he was desperate to
stop Trump and yet they used if they
signed a document in front of a judge
that said we vouch for the reliability
and authenticity of this document in
other words they were lying to the judge
that's a crime 18 USC 242 you it's abuse
of power and it's it's tragic that the
people that we expect to uphold and
enforce the law are breaking it this is
the proof so Sebastian they this is what
they knew they knew that dossier was
false
they knew that Hillary Clinton paid for
the dossier they never told the judge
they knew the guy that was responsible
Steele hated Donald Trump and didn't
want him to win they knew they couldn't
spy on a trump associate without the
dossier they were shut down the first
attempt they tried to get it and then
they got it on the second shot and admit
without it they never would have got it
so let's just remember what happened 11
months ago the president tweeted out
that his campaign had been spied upon he
was ridiculed by the left in the
mainstream media we now know not only is
it true that he was spied upon by the
Obama administration but the warrant was
acquired illegally
I had a chief of police text me today
and he said if any of his officers had
acquired a warrant
while excluding exculpatory information
that Officer would be charged with
perjury or abuse of power and not only
that this is fascinating
let's unwind all of it congressman Gates
just reminded me on the 16th of May Rod
Rosenstein excess corded robert muller
to be interviewed by the president to be
the director of the FBI again he failed
the interview the president wanted
somebody new he didn't want a bush a
bush heir a person the next day May the
17th after he fails that interview rod
Rosenstein appoints him as the special
counsel to investigate
president how can he investigate the
president in a subjective fashion and
lastly lastly what about all the
congressmen and women who lied about
this memo for four days they've been
telling us it would reveal sources and
methods that's par for the course none
of which no Simmons yeah all right let
me go to Sarah sir it's about a year ago
you broke this story my sources tell me
this is just the tip of the spear the
tip of the iceberg and that there's so
much more to come I was given a
percentage about 15% of what is coming
what are your sources telling you you
were dead-on accurate on March 8th of
last year my sources are telling me it's
10 percent of what is coming so maybe
there's even more Shawn out there than
what we expect and this is even more
important the investigation is now going
to be reversed I know that members of
Congress are going to call for a special
counsel to investigate the investigators
there is going to be a number of people
involved in this also the information as
you reported that's going to the IG
they're they're going to look at
criminality here was there anything
criminal going on and from what
appearances look like there was so they
lied to the FISA courts allegedly and
that's what they're going to be looking
at
I tell you Sean this is just the
beginning this is not the end and the
investigation is in Reverse last
thoughts where is this going I don't
know but I can tell you a congressional
source tells me that rod Rosen Stein in
a meeting three weeks ago threatened the
Chairman newness and members of Congress
that he was going to subpoena their
texts and messages because he was tired
of dealing with the Intel committee
that's that's an intimidation and
retaliation all of you have been doing
the work of the media for an entire year
and sharing it with our audience I can't
thank you all enough I wish it didn't
happen though we have a lot of cleaning
up to do